no no no no no no he's a sweet talker  or is he just is it just playing he's  playing he's got he's he's  got game yeah you got games 100 times  it depends in what context  are you understanding female nature  or are you trying to understand what  women want  wait what do you mean so like i i don't  know how to phrase this but like you'll  find  for example  a beta male or simp may  be catering to  what the woman wants  as opposed to understanding the game and  understanding what a woman needs that's  true  what women want  can be anything under the sun we don't  even know  oh i'll do this want this  okay exactly however if a man  understands what women need  it can be she can be telling you what  she wants you put in place what she  needs and she make should i either  conform or